[Musique]
c'est au rythme des applaudissements et
des trompettes que la lie quand
gouverneur a fait son entrée en chambre
dans son discours des références à
l'inflation et à l'incertitude
économique
mais hormis ces quelques phrases les
priorités du gouvernement avait des airs
de déjà vu
en avril quelques jours avant de
déclencher des élections le gouvernement
ford avait présenté un budget axé sur
l'investissement en infrastructures
après un scrutin qui aura donné aux
progressistes-conservateurs une large
majorité le gouvernement revient à la
charge en déposant un budget quasi
identique à celui du printemps
quelques changements mineurs y ont été
apportées comme une aide financière
additionnelle pour les parents et les
personnes en situation de handicap
mairie pour répondre à la crise
grandissante dans les hôpitaux de la
province où la pénurie de personnel a
récemment forcé la fermeture temporaire
de plusieurs urgences
car jacking
pour faire face à cette crise les
infirmières réclament entre autres une
augmentation salariale une demande à
laquelle le gouvernement n'a pas donné
suite dans son budget what we need et
cayenne massive des pick of crisis of
fame and bike tarn entre la pénurie de
personnel dans les hôpitaux et
l'inflation galopante le 2 mandat de doc
word commence avec deux grandes crises à
gérer et même avec une majorité
écrasante et face à une opposition
affaiblie le premier ministre devra
répondre à des questions difficiles et
peut-être même revoir certaines de ses
priorités ici des radio canada toronto